so
i know that this game cult of the lamb
everybody that's what we're playing
today very excited about it massive
monster uh i believe is australian um
you can see the victoria government down
there
shout out to victoria mate i believe
chat can play so i was gonna just do my
regular like
play an hour of the video game and
upload it on the internet sorry on
youtube but i decided to stream this one
specifically
praise the lamb conduit to great power
promised liberator
yet sacrificial beast take heed for a
crown cannot sit upon two brows what
does that mean
um i wanted to stream it because i know
that there is chat integration which
sounds like it's pretty cool
[Music]
i do not so the game comes out tomorrow
i do not believe that chat needs the
game
um
that said i don't know exactly how it
works maybe it's in setting connect with
twitch it's right there connect with
twitch
let's check it out
that's us
viewers can spend channel points which
fill up your twitch totem bar oh wow
when this bar is full you will receive a
reward help or hinder events will happen
automatically they allow viewers to vote
on either giving you a bonus or
punishing you
allow viewers to enter a raffle to
create your next follower the follower
will be designed by the viewers and will
display their name this sounds really
cool
what a really smart integration um also
we are still raising money for
protection from abuse which is a
wonderful organization
uh that helps many victims of many kinds
of abuse um if you type the charity
command in chat otherwise i'll leave it
in the link if i post this on youtube
sorry link in the description
i'm liking the lighting a lot
okay
i guess
all others we have hunted down and put
to the blade with this final sacrifice
prophecy will be impossible to confirm
the heretic who lies bound below will be
condemned to eternal captivity and the
old faith shall be preserved
all right you seem like a couple of fun
guys
[Music]
what an opening
that's east
heaven i definitely just got decapitated
i think this is the only game i've ever
played that starts directly with the
decapitation
was it wolfenstein the new order does
start with a pretty quick
i think he gets decapitated but it's not
you it's your friend come closer fear
not for though you are already dead i
still have need of you
those few foolish bishops thought they
could keep you from me and death but
instead they sent you straight to me i
will give you life again but at a price
dude i'm very into the vibe of this game
i feel like i should turn my light off
all i ask is for you to start a cult in
my name do we have a deal
okay sounds good to me
hey thank you hound of colon
thank you
alright
i am butter lamb or slaughter
[Music]
thank you hump pillow
um
okay
ooh
combat feels great so far i mean it's
very simple but
feels good man
a lot more impactful than i expected
the the jewelsense popping off right now
i appreciate your contributions to the
totem
uh my fellow followers of the dapple
i think
[Laughter]
okay
dude
they're like shifting aspects
this game is very stylish
uh fear not i am rattau i was once a
chosen vessel like you but those days
are lost to the winds
i was sent to guide you a deep in the
lands of the old faith and in grave
danger my instructions are to lead you
to safety continue through the woods
escape flies ahead i will be close by
all right
oh yes zubats
in every doc cave
open inventory
okay
i have no followers devastating cult
needs followers dude
fleece of the lamb noble god fit the
leader of a cult so i am the cult leader
thank you again humpty pillow
who humped you
[Music]
oh yes
i don't know what the coins all do is it
going to be like
uh cosmetic stuff maybe
i feel like
the purple headband that i'm wearing
today
to keep my stupid headwind intact
kind of suits the vibe
i wonder how difficult this is going to
get to and obviously right now this is
just combat but
[Music]
the music is well i'm very impressed by
this so far you'll
thank you cat lava
okay
thank you rowan cruz i appreciate that
thank you
we've nearly reached safety but look
ahead another poor soul about to be
sacrificed rescue them and they would
have no choice but to join in at all
okay
oh mighty bishops of the old faith we
ask you to accept the sacrifice of this
wretched soul
hey who interrupts our ritual and
trespasses on sacred ground
hit me
stop mate
how you doing
you are
absolutely dead mate
not a
chance i don't know what these little
guys are but they mad cute too little
little rock clams oh my gosh
it's a little pig
[Music]
follower awaits indoctrination that's
the most metal thing i've ever heard
all right let's go indoctrinate a
follow-up baby
we have reached safety you have done
well
the red crown will allow you
to use those markings on the ground to
transport yourself great distances
it will take you to a temple that has
fallen to ruin there you will be able to
begin your new call i will
give unto the blood of god
heretics defeated yeah get out of here
oh is am i supposed to be doing this
quickly
good to know
select a difficulty uh
well let's start with medium because
it's developer recommended and then go
up to hard i used to play every game on
hard
but i stopped after some time i'll go
through that yet um
because i realized it was making me play
less games because things would take
longer
ground which once was mine is now yours
this crumbling ruin
is to be the site of your new cult he
counts as a follower doesn't he or is he
like more of like
a business partner
it's just like age of empires
o2 byz said time limit intervals between
cult donation
okay
gotcha okay
so you guys twitch chat has
a timer oh twitch didn't say i went live
that makes sense we had a lot less
viewers today than normal
not that it matters yeah for a good time
all right let's indoctrinate a goddash
ping
god dash ping
i meant a god damn pig
wow
okay
isn't this the part that twitch is
supposed to be allowed to help with or
is that the new followers
[Music]
i'm not going to change your name
choose form
i mean i don't feel like i want to
change any of it to be honest
maybe
maybe make you purple now you're here
nah i feel like i'll remember you better
this way traits
i can't change these these are as they
are
oh follow a raffle i missed it okay
let's give it a try
start raffle
so now i think this means y'all get to
customize
somehow
did anything pop up
[Music]
oh you can
lower the global cooldown of the chat
point thing on the chat point redemption
thing in the dashboard okay
so this is not working
because there are no participants
the extension isn't installed
let me try again
it says it's set up
that one says it's set up that one says
it's set up set up
your totem is followers customize that
should be done
yep
the totem couldn't be set up because
channel one already exists
activate
that maybe
here okay did that work
i think that worked
cool
okay
so now i think you go i want to join the
cult
[Music]
32 all right
the raffle is in progress
[Music]
do i end the raffle after there are a
certain amount of participants
[Music]
this music's great i'm into a lot of
facets of this game so far
um all right let's end it
follow a creation in progress ghost msl
has won the raffle welcome to the cult
welcome
thanks for letting me know detune i
appreciate it
all right very cute looking good looking
good this is really cool integration
what a neat uh
oh he looks like banjo
what a cool thing to do all right
so i can't change these but i did want
to read them
against sacrifice minus five faith when
a follower is sacrificed i don't know i
could do that
lose minus five faith when another
follower dies and generates devotion
fifteen percent slower wow dude ye of
little faith banjo
ah
he's super cute
[Music]
no no you're totally helping i
appreciate it
okay
go chop trees son
[Music]
followers cannot live on prayer alone
they must eat
gather the necessary resources to build
a cooking fire okay
i have to collect lumber myself
okay
this game is so stylish
wow
how cool i'm super impressed
[Music]
i don't need any more of that i just
need stone
mind the big boy i love the animation
[Music]
is this working
yeah that's gonna be too slow though
ain't nobody got time for that what's
the glowy thing
[Music]
i would like to know what glows
the little faces
oh my
okay technically i have everything
build cooking fire you say
here
[Music]
it seems like it should go in the middle
it can't okay
put it right here
[Music]
cool
your followers need to eat and it's up
to you to provide meals for them uh
freeloaders
the hunger of your cult can be seen on
the top left of the screen and when this
gets too low followers will begin to
starve
find more food while crusading pick
routes that pass through foraging
locations oh okay
noted
plant farms to grow your own food seeds
can be purchased or found whilst
crusading
uh yeah sometimes it sends it for some
people mighty kratos gaming and not for
other people um
but it did seem like that's been
happening to me recently
this is not berry it is okay berries uh
debary's growing bushes i actually have
no concept
more more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i know that technically i don't need
this many but uh i wanted to clear it
out i wanted to make it look tidy okay
can i i can talk to you ghost msl your
banjo look alike
no you're already doing everything you
need to you're doing a great job
okay basic variable let's go
i imagine that gets harder as you go
[Music]
now we must build a shrine but first we
will need more followers and more gold
both of which can be found when
crusading through the lands of all the
old things
a mutual benefactor the one who waits
has been trapped by the four bishops of
the old faith each of them guards a
chain that binds him to the realm beyond
ooh this is very wheel of time
any wheel of time fans out there is very
wheel of time
we have conjured openings to their
realms it is your task to track them
down and slay them so that he may be
free get rid of those seals yo
now go there you should find gold and
willing recruits and for those who are
not willing convert them by force
i don't love that for me but if i have
to
welcome hound of cullen
i appreciate your contribution to
the uh totem thank you
for the one who waits we appreciate your
service sir
thank you mighty kratos
thank you yeah i followed the god of war
tag on uh instagram which is probably
how i found what you're talking about
and some of the art and stuff people
post on that tag is incredible a lot of
really cool cosplay see
uh do you want to go to darkwood do we
want to go to anchor deep can't go
they're not enough followers
just like real life am i right
it's probably i'm probably only gonna be
able to go to that one seven uh
duh
oh spiders
i am very scared of spiders
they are my number one fear outside of
losing my family it's probably my actual
number one fear
but um
the other day
i built a fence
and put it up
by myself
even though the bush is next to where i
built the fence
are full of spiders and i am really
proud of myself
younger alana would never have done that
she would have just been like nope gotta
pay somebody
i'm not going anywhere near it guess it
won't get built but i did it i just wore
gloves and a long sleeve shirt
and i was scared
independent women who don't need no man
etc
i wonder if uh i will get like magic
casting abilities or something at some
point
all right let's roll
if i'm picking up blades of grass i
don't even realize
damn y'all are fast dude
you're a little sneaky little sneaky
boys nope okay they do give you a really
long window
give me gold and followers
yeah so they just splash white before
they're gonna attack i guess it could
get overwhelming if there was a really
busy screen but
it's indicated quite clearly it's almost
like uh
like you did flight tests on this here
video game huh
that's what it's looking like to me my
friends
you really hard to figure out uh what
play is what cues plays willa and won't
notice
if you are a person who has developed
the game
because you know it so you don't know
what user what thank you brandon rights
thank you for your contribution to the
totem the cult really appreciates
your input um
if you leave you'll die
okay
so brandon
that's it for you now
you're staying here now all right okay
that's on you bud
praise the lamb conduit to great power
promised liberator of the one that waits
below there's no way that clonic
actually sounds like that there's just
no way
um
it's not it's not their vibe i apologize
for misrepresenting cloning
so the cards showed me once many
lifetimes ago was that yet to be i've
always drawn your card slam and yet this
is the first take these cards and i will
draw another each time we meet when
drawn by me they will grant you power
okay level system
what power well that is both known and
unfathomable the cards they shall decide
i love the voice acting as well very
cool
a heart off is a vowel made
receive double health when healing
i don't actually know which of these i
need yet
i'm gonna go with that
[Music]
because it seems like a good bit
thanks man what's this
just the cards i have seen okay cool
so that is sort of a levels of song
i don't know if this is randomly
generated you know i i do not i do not
know
oh the blow one got me
did you throw something at me sir get
out of here
cash money
[Music]
damn okay
[Music]
so
let's go get food
oh
i didn't expect that to be like
little towns also a really interesting
way of denoting that it exists but you
can't approach it how cool
damn this game
rules from what i
gathered i expected like cute animal
crossing vibes but um
and again similar to stray
that's like sometimes something that you
can just lean on and just do
and you would get a bunch of money
because people would be like oh haha
it's cult animal crossing that's so
funny and cute and you'd make a bunch of
money and i'm always like you know
that's probably someone made that as a
mobile game uh already and you don't
have to put the effort in to make that
sell
but they did
but this is really cool
thank you halora welcome to the cult uh
praise be to the one who waits below did
i get the food i don't think i did is
there anything else to do here
hello
this is sick man look at him look at him
they're huge
uh
how much is it i don't know you know i'm
sorry
i did pick up berries okay thank you
are we back to start
[Music]
um it is out tomorrow on steam though
so
check it out tomorrow
i was provided a code by default digital
clarissa one of my
favorite pr people in the whole industry
she's wonderful
just breaking stuff for fun it's very
zelda in that way it's like the
the fun of breaking pots is here
the frame rate drops that oh
[Music]
oh
oh it's one of the bishops
sleshie how can this be
whoa thank you for the raid
thank you rebs i appreciate it welcome
everybody
playing cult of the lamb
this game comes out tomorrow it is
wonderful thus far
uh we're also raising money for charity
if you uh want to donate type charity
command and chat it'll come up we're
about to hit 20 000
for an organization called protection
against abuse
okay you were put to the blade lamb as
all your kind were and yet here you
stand before me unrepentant
the crown his power could it be
yeah but i am stronger still turn tail
and run little lamb i probably should
for now run away but i imagine i get to
kill the bishops at some point
i just don't feel like today is that day
as i only have one measly follower and
like three berry bowls
and maybe 50 bucks in cash to my name
it's just not enough
not yet i wonder what the grass does
and i don't seem to be picking up rocks
when i do this am i picking up this time
oh i am okay
i may as well just kind of chop up
everything then good thing they made it
fun
hello clonic
attack rate increased by 1.5 or reveal
the map
that one
duh thank you i just don't feel like i
need to know the map yet i may regret
that choice later
but for now
hey we gucci hey
are we
okay bishop bishop
same bishop you've come far enough
little lamb my followers are willing to
do anything for me can you say the same
of yours i only have one
i give myself to the cause oh mighty
leader
by the blood of the great ones destroy
the red crown that's that's mine
what are you summoning who gave you the
wreck to summon you summoned yourself
ugly
up
damn i can do that too okay you just
just give me like a couple of days of
only eating chocolate and i'll get
breakouts
and then maybe like
i don't sleep for a while
i haven't showered in a few days you
summoned ugly a lot faster than me we
can all do it
doesn't make you powerful
would you like to be recruited
convert media occult i will follow your
teachings faithfully
come through bro [ __ ] come through
let's go
um
i'm gonna go with the gold nugs
okay
i will return to my call thank you
i have one more follower and i'm pretty
sure i'm rich
[Music]
cool
the game is really fun reefs it is so
far i'm really enjoying it we've only
been playing for about 25 minutes but
wait didn't i get another follower how
did he did he not join me
you have returned have not returned
that's what i said let us indoctrinate
this new convert so that we may continue
all right bud all right we're going to
let twitch do this one again
there you go
follow a raffle has begun there should
be an overlay
for you to click that says i want to
join the cult to everybody who's
watching live on twitch and then you
become a participant and once there are
i don't know wait a minute or so
uh we will end the raffle and one of you
will win and you will get to become a
follower
um it's not a link it should just be an
overlay on the stream if you're not
seeing it um i think detune who was in
here helping before said to just try and
refresh
and it should show up
it was showing for me so it's definitely
there i mean there are 61 people here
it's definitely working uh
crank gameplay is playing skater xl of
course he is
[Music]
when it gets to 69 i'm gonna do it ah we
passed it it counts okay
the lurker surfer has won the raffle
welcome to the cult
you i
get called out for lurking here not a
lurker today friend you are now
part of the cult
and you get to choose what the next
little follower is going to look like my
friend
yeah it sounds like it only works on pc
does not seem to work on um
mobile please drink the kool-aid drink
as much of the kool-aid as is humanly
possible because i need it to beat the
bishops
praise the one who waits
all right very cute very cute very cute
and your traits are positive ignores
dissenters when they preach nice
didn't know that was the thing that they
would do
gain faith when building better sleeping
quarters okay so i should make him do
that
generates devotion at 15 percent slower
hey bud welcome to the cold i like your
shirt hello
uh
you can go get stone
fellows will either work or worship
worshipping followers generate devotion
for you to flex so neither of the two
that i have are any good about
generating devotion not that i know what
it does yet
but to collect devotion you require a
shrine there you go
build a shrine i would love to welcome
shadowstorm welcome to the cult thank
you for contributing to the totem
praise the one who waits
yes dude
that's a sick bro
let's go let's go let's go let's go
[Music]
thank god that's all i needed to do to
get you guys to worship me
so i just had to build a shrine this
whole time that's it
come on
you should have told me i i mean i do
already have a batman shrine
[Music]
you know again it's you've no i've never
posted a picture of it and it's not on
my streams but
you know what i mean
it's what i'm saying
like i don't already have a shrine
[Music]
it's just uh
all right come on come on camera
you're okay or not
i have to realign that but it was worth
it i already have a shrine
okay
praise be your followers can now worship
you
yeah we are a batman cult but also the
one who waits could be batman i'd buy
that
here's a new follower assign them to
worship at the shrine and then collect
the devotion your followers generate at
the shrine to unlock divine inspiration
you just gave me a new follower oh my
god
i will spare you
as long as you devote your entire life
to me
start raffle let's go
this is really cool boo thank you for
contributing uh to the totem oh tbyz
praised to the one who waits
this is your life now
[Music]
this music's so sick
oh what a cool game
okay
i'm gonna end it there
lanka dycicle has won the raffle welcome
to the cult my friend i'm gonna have yo
ass worship at a shrine
so
that's what you signed up for okay you
clicked the thing not me all right
praise be to the one who waits
very cute
okay what are your traits
coprophiliac gained 10 faith when
falling ill wow okay
i mean that probably happens a lot to be
honest that's probably pretty genuine
that people in times of distress like
become more devoted which is bad but
materialistic gain faith when building
better sleeping quarters okay a couple
of you
could be vibing like that where we
currently don't have sleeping quarters
i'm real hard on scientology right now
basically
collective ocean from your shrine once
you collect enough you will unlock
divine inspiration
the more followers worshipping at the
shrine the faster they will fill up if
the shrine is full they will stop
washing worshipping until it is emptied
okay what does it do
once you have collected divine
inspiration unlock new buildings ah
i must be
praised
in order to
build
of course oh interesting
thank you for the
that's a lot of food
yeah let's cook what else can we cook
amiga mixed meal let's do it
and some more berry foods gonna cook for
the homies
do they just eat by themselves i'm
assuming that they do
oh is this where the totem contributions
from twitch go i see you're doing a way
better job than
just this one
temple
it has to be the temple okay
establish a temple to preach sermons and
perform rituals
this game's sick dude
wow okay let's go
i do want the sleeping quarters i
understand that we can't
what
you said what now
i'm very good go step myself very good
amazing
ah nice one scott thank you uh praise be
to uh the one who waits welcome to the
cult i really appreciate what you've
done for us here so i did get the temple
right yeah
uh can i build it
not yet
we need more wood and more stone
which i know i can get in the world but
why not just
do it here it probably won't even let me
go out right now because i'm still in
tutorial face so
i've got to collect lumber and stone in
it
that doesn't bode well well it bodes
fine just not for me
or rather not for everyone else it bodes
fine for me it's what i meant to say i
i'm not gonna be thrown in the body pit
otherwise who would manage it you need
somebody to manage your body pit
that's the the biggest tip i can give
you for surviving in a workplace is make
yourself irreplaceable you know
if you're the guy
who works at a place that has a body pit
all you have to do is manage operations
of the body pit and then everyone's like
well we can't throw him in the body pit
because then we'd have to do that work
okay
it's easy
it's easy
i got you
you stay alive out here
you liv nutty pumpkin put this up
okay
[Music]
i'm just gonna mine this entire
landscape um
except for the big stone things
that can probably be
for the workers
all right
well thank you sethi thank you so much
i appreciate you my friend sethi 445
thank you thank you thank you
if i do another
lo-fi beats
[Music]
um
mix
putting songs from this song and it
would be awesome
all right that's gonna do me for now
okay except this one
what this looks like it's such a
pleasant place for us to
make a body pit you know that's all i'm
saying
all right
where do you put your temple
i feel like maybe your temple sort of
goes on the outskirts you know
like because i can't put it in the
center that's where the shrine is
putting it right in front of the shrine
would sort of make sense
[Music]
yeah i don't know i feel like your
simon's just sort of go in the corner
welcome simple man aka sean appreciate
your contribution to the totem
it really means a lot
praise be
to the one who waits our lord and savior
of the underworld or whatever
i'm not a determined face when he runs
the temple is the center of your cult
from there you'll preach sermons to grow
stronger and perform rituals to mold the
fragile minds of your followers
you are responsible for maintaining the
faith of your cult if it falls too low
your followers will descend against you
and eventually leave
your followers are ready to hear you
show them that you are their great
leader preacher sermon from within your
temple all alright let's go
actually let me just collect some faith
first
thank you i receive your devotion
what are somes
it's a midnight mass reference
[Music]
damn okay through the faith of your
followers you grow stronger
[Music]
performing sermons will draw power from
them and allow you to unlock new
abilities weapons and curses i knew
there would be new weapons and curses
you let me cast spells baby
followers with a higher loyalty level
will generate more devotion and
therefore the more followers you have
and the more loyal they are the quicker
arts of the faithful
sure or can i look at other things
yeah i mean it wants me to go this one
obviously
so let's let's let the tutorial tutorial
shall we
thank you
make old tiger hi elon i'm currently
dealing with an effective woman myself
so your video about what you're going
through really hit me
i'm sorry to hear that my friend
and same which is why i'm still wearing
the headband
it's very annoying um okay cool hey uh
great salmon everybody that was sick
that was
sick you are amazing to behold the
natural leader i see why you were chosen
if you are to guide your cult you will
need to declare doctrine so that they
might obey you
return return to the lands of old faith
and seek out commandment stone fragments
with these you'll be able to declare new
doctrines all right
hey six seven today guys thanks for
coming really you guys you you did a
great job everybody did a great job
i thought simon today was sick bro
okay yeah i have none
all right lads hey good job out there
hey
you know what
the lord is pleased with you
when i throw you in the body pit
it uh you uh you'll be remembered fondly
it's something about the afterlife
all right okay yeah
yeah eat your food all right
all right good stuff lads hey
you stop working i will murder you all
right have a good one catch whoa hey
catch y'all later
all right have a good one thanks
everyone good chat good chat great
summon great something thanks for
showing up
uh
i don't have enough followers for this
one yet because it requires seven this
is gonna be like a million right
those are boss fight vibes if ever i've
seen them that's where the bishops will
be
this is for next one i think maybe i
could still only go through this one
i wonder what the red
see how it's got like a
controller vibration desk uh like a red
motorcycle
[Music]
oh
an x
no i prefer the sword
i can't swap back
uh i suppose i cannot
okay that's all right i did prefer the
sword though because the axe feels slow
get over here nerd
hey
hey leshi so you foolishly persist
little anne
ikeo lies and i smell your fear
the red crown rises again
your goddamn ride it does i tell you
what if my guy had a one
i tell you what
get out of here zubat not today
[Music]
yeah i'm i'm very very impressed with
this game um
in terms of like design and would not be
surprised if it ends up nominated for
some awards like
the art style the way that this
tutorialization is working is so
cohesive and so easy to pick up
plus the music
i'm i'm a very big fan
we absolutely can't go so myself but
thank you crow seven blah
um
yeah i just really
really feel like they they nailed the
vision
it's good directing is what it is when
all the pieces just really tie into each
other seamlessly and there's no bloat
and
it's very pleasant even though it's very
dark it's very impressive i wonder how
big the team is
but also i will like i'm always a shill
for aussie games nice scott love your
devotion to the totem really appreciate
the devotion my friend
thank you for what you're doing for the
cold praise the one who waits
uh let's go this
i'm just out here trying to find
commandment stones to tell my homies
what to do
okay
overall weapon damage increased gain and
extra hard i'm gonna
[Music]
do this one for now because i'm not i'm
not having trouble
with
health just yet
[Music]
i'm glad i found you i bring good news
the one who waits is pleased with your
progress and wishes to grant you a crown
ability okay okay the devil
okay yes yes dude yes the answer is yes
i am thankful for his blessings praise
be to the one who waits enemies you slay
will now drop further collectors to
replenish your
curses further is a righteous anger
owned by striking down non-believers and
works like ammunition for your curses oh
god
further will drop when you slay an enemy
collecting it refuels your curses tight
very chill good vibes
had by all
oh okay so i can only use it as i'm
collecting it i suppose
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Music]
hello big chest
what are you a new card
10 chance of gaming hot when it's
killing an enemy i don't know actually
if there's a difference between the two
kinds of hearts though um
i don't know if there's a difference
between the red hearts and the
and the blue ones
well hello
who's this then
yes
one can be certain of nothing but the
heart's affections
i'm gonna do that obviously aren't i
blueprint oh that would be dude
i can buy that i don't know how much
money i have
i'm gonna do this one
cool
and i'll buy it
i don't know what else to use money on
tara caught unlocked increased curse
attack damage by 1.25 beautiful
wee gucci oh i'm getting through those
pretty fast i don't know how long this
game is
[Music]
okay
[Music]
cool
thanks have a good day
[Music]
that's a follow-up
i'm assuming
good day
oh it's a bunny
the worm it is hungry it feeds it
partakes of our flesh but that is the
price for safety for that we gladly give
it all we have that sounded like slam
poetry my queen
okay it does take a lot of
a lot of hits
no you don't i thought you was dead
oh it's really fun
all right
let's go
[Music]
come on now
let me just break some stuff yeah yeah
yeah don't hey don't you worry if
there's anything i'm gonna do to that
follower is indoctrinate them don't you
[ __ ] worry about it
let's go home
rescuing once
steel devotion
okay
will we go to new divine inspiration
i'll take that that seemed pretty risky
what i just did there stealing devotion
but
arrow eons are gone these lands were
rife with gods and their adherents
what befell this pantheon are last is
the nature of beasts to forget and gods
to be forgotten that's a really
beautiful sentence
mayhap they left mayhap they slept
mayhap they devoured and were devoured
in turn those few who remain spread
roots spun webs moulded this world to
meet them and theirs
it was the land of many gods once
hundreds now
well there's one more
beautiful
[Music]
commandment stones are used to declare
you doctrines for your cult to follow
yes
use the altar in your temple to declare
a new doctrine whenever you form a new
commandment stone i would love to
let's
i can feel fate's hand on the cards this
night all right
damages everything on screen when hit
get down to all enemies ah let's get
that one that's still a great game
your card's been drawn the path lays
ahead
i think you'll find the pathways this
way
[Music]
all right
yeah this game is lovely um like i said
it's out tomorrow i'm pretty sure
thank you dosa pros for contributing
your devotion to the totem
we here at
uh
cult incorporated really appreciate that
sacrifice your life for us today
valapha more like dead of fall
oh okay okay we need some kind of video
game
i see you doing video games out here
i ran right into it that's my beak
he's not dropping any further either
so i just kind of gotta wait oh oh
that's too many hops you've never done
that many hops before
get out of here that's too many
are you some like some hoppy boy these
days
not today little baby
not today
hey honey it's all cool i know we just
fought and stuff but would you like to
be indoctrinated into my cult
type
let's take this
one
[Music]
thank you
all right
i see it has given me another one so i
probably gotta do this two more times
before i've like exhausted the dungeon i
suppose
please be the one who waits
all right
raise me
um
fernando what the retirement package for
colt incorporated look like
very good you will love your time
in the body pit
don't be put off by the name
trust in your cult leader and the one
who waits
he praised me to him he would never let
us down
um
your time in the body pit will be
warm full of friends
there's
it there's there's a there's a smell
which could be received positively
potentially
it's um
unparalleled good vibes
exactly body pit
sexy
just depends how you
it's uh it's up to you how you
wanna see that
um i i may be your cult leader but i'm
i'm not a control freak thank you
captain quirk
feel devotion to the cult nice all right
oh well i feel like you've already been
converted you've really done the work
for me natura
all right twitch chat let's go
you can you can uh
make make the bunny cute
oh thank you pu i appreciate that never
lonely in the body pit your retirement
plan
is
very
social
you will never feel alone
which is what everyone fears when they
die
not to say you're going to die
i
didn't mean that
all right you'll have a great time
[Music]
then i end it when there's a hundred
[Music]
the song is lovely
no free cookies but i do cook for you
which i don't think that many cult
leaders do to be honest only the ones
who you cyanide
congratulations one clever fawn for
winning the raffle welcome to the cult
my friend
[Music]
customize this
little uh
follower however you please
make yourself cute af to not be
sacrificed who said anything about
sacrifice
stop bringing your bad vibes in here you
are very cute one clip before nice work
very cute very cute very cute
all right what are your traits zealous
ignores descendants when they preach
nice natural skeptic on recruiting
follow immediately at least 10 faith wow
okay
i don't love that for me but
fine
you could go worship
i don't really have need for the other
stuff just yet
i don't know what the sleeping bags do
farm plot let's go with this for now
because i'm curious
very unstable will often well it doesn't
sound great
but it's a start
[Music]
what is a sleeping bag
collapse mean
i only need one
[Music]
can i get it now
no i don't have to divide it for
inspiration for it hey what's up what's
going on
[Music]
who do you think you are
leave then
on sanitary conditions at your call will
cause your followers to become sick if a
follower becomes sick assign them to bed
rest or they could die resting will
allow them to slowly recover oh look how
cute
that is the little sick
uh avatar vomit and dead bodies cause
illness to spread quickly throughout
your cold
cleaning masses and varying bodies will
prevent display and illness
there are messes
[Music]
thank you superman aka sean for your
contribution to the totem
where's poop
you guys just been pooping in the yard
out here
oh
what i gotta clean up your what are you
tamagotchis
what's wrong with you no it's fertilizer
nice that's gonna be good for the crops
well at least you pooped sort of
away
all right let's go create uh
oh i can collect a reward from you ghost
where'd you go here you're going to
reward me
you wanted me great leader i'm eternally
grateful you're damn right
um okay declare any drop doctrine from
i do want to do this though let's do
this
where
would you sleep maybe like a little
sleepy bed like sort of in front of the
shrine
i don't know
[Music]
i guess
seems chill
that way if somebody does get sick
like the weaklings they are
you could sleep it off um
from the altar and your temple okay
it's doctrine time baby
let's go
um
i'd like to do that
declare a new doctrine yes
what are we declaring
[Music]
dance around the flame to increase the
cult's faith
okay
do we have a bonfire
i don't recall
all right
no not yet okay
[Music]
and we could just do a sermon just for
fun
it's gotta
entertain the homies demand their
undying loyalty
bane weapons
curse of the horde that sounds sick
let's go
i want the gold sword
rituals okay
yeah let's manipulate
oh i don't have the needed things for
that all right that's it that's it lads
hey hey great simon tonight great sermon
tonight y'all preaching sermons
performing rituals and providing for the
needs of your followers will keep their
faith high the bones of your enemies are
required to perform oh okay
destroy the skeletons together in their
bones return to the lands of old faith
gather the bones from fallen enemies
recruit my followers and return to
perform a ritual here
in the temple
cool
is this outdoor in any stores or just in
the morning uh i take the couch i got an
early code i think i've had the game for
about two weeks but um i wanted to wait
for the twitch integration though i
think you may have been able to earlier
the email i got said embarca was today
um but no it is out tomorrow i got a
code thanks to developer digi digital
for providing me with a code let's
recruit this last follower
and then i'm actually gonna
end the stream for today everybody just
a quick one i want to play this again
this is really fun
i'm enjoying it thank you dr peppa
and congratulations romulux that's
awesome congratulations
um all right one more
let's go it should be up on your screen
now
if you would like to join the cult
you can we'll make one more
little
follower
[Music]
the cult has a great retirement plan i
promise
you will never be lonely
praise be
to the one who waits
[Music]
corpse pit is um i think it's body pit
do you get dental um
uh we'll talk about that in the next
seven you can't
it's very impolite if you just throw
questions like that at me
hr at the next summon we'll run you
through
dental
opportunities
crazy
all right
and raffle let's go
[Music]
dr peppa511
i totally just saw you in chat has won
the raffle welcome to the cult follower
creation in progress
do you get pedicures definitely not
definitely not no
um frankly we don't even have bathrooms
you have to poop in the yard and i have
to clean up after you like the little
[ __ ] tamagotchi
um but yeah i really like this game i
was expecting to but i didn't expect it
to have as much depth or perhaps as much
commitment um
for whatever reason
and
i think it's wonderful i love the music
the art style this i'm obviously still
in the tutorial here very significantly
and i'm really liking the
tutorialization i think the twitch
aspects are really really fun like just
a really really cool
uh
unique approach
it's very very very cool the fact that
my
followers are
actually all people from twitch is very
very very cool uh it makes me only want
to play the game on twitch
and your traits are strong constitution
heals fifteen percent passive one sick
and embed rest and working devotion
generation speed reduced but you're lazy
[ __ ]
straight to the body pit with you you
know what i'm saying
[Music]
so you can worship
collect totem reward i wonder what the
twitch one does
i'll take food it's fine
all right that's gonna be it for me
today everybody this is super fun again
thank you to devolver digital for
sending me a code this is not sponsored
in any way they just sent me the code
for the game which i'm sure i would have
checked out anyway
um
i really really like it
it's a very good time
and yeah very fun to play with twitch
thank you for joining me
uh if i play the game again i'll make
sure i stream it because i think this is
the ideal way to play it and
i'll probably try and do that another
point this week so
thank you all for hanging out